when to welcome to this video playing
[ __ ] game ok let's go neither three I
really am curious let me check that I
want to know with white I have exactly
the same number of games with wine and
black I always feel that I play against
him with black against us is b3 this
stuff is Lars inner opening I don't know
sometimes sometimes we we probably a a
very selective way of memorizing things
94 interesting interesting so if i take
d 4 it's not leading to anything home ok
so keep it simple check
okay we can take on d4 and see forward
arrows cannot quite believe that this is
good okay m night b5 crude very crude
but what is he doing against at d5 maybe
d5 actually yes that's possible and then
queena for caveman style today it could
work it could work
let's see I mean probably yes to go to
five I mean yeah so clean air for hats a
gotta move you cannot really believe
that that it works okay so Queen f4 yeah
but what is this what is this reply
against this some would be a door
something i also have quick weenie five
is also a threat amazingly enough he
cannot interpose something yeah Queenie
five check 2697 and Bishop e7 96 yeah
that that's that leaves you with these
kind of moves okay and interesting so
what now the most natural movie is a
form just blasted open let's do it I
just open this position night before the
screen to f7 yeah here I was thinking
sorry I'm just Knight c3 on something
better I don't know let's go Knight c3
yeah here t5 let's queen to d6 so most
logical is probably to open the position
and then route the one jeff now let's do
it d one queen here that's go into is
six now that this is not so bad fam at
least i don't see anything too
convincing the king will probably have
some decent place on b7 well my
development is also not that fantastic
45 probably not that the king is super
safe but it feels kind of okay van
[Music]
I don't want to trade really now let's
go through t3 anyway trading is not not
great rook to e3 the screen g5 at least
also having twin g7 maybe you can try
some counter-attack with III that looks
like a good actor move you three is a
good move no didn't do it ok I thought
I'd be five would be a bit annoying
still my player 3 but ok
I couldn't if I for something anyway I
need to speed up speed up
he takes it i can take a several yeah
it takes me six time morning okay seven
hmm i don't know if that works but it's
kind of too late for considerations yeah
like that kim taek's Quincy five is made
so he has to go there and now let's see
check on f4 look these six looks pretty
awkward maybe also just clean be five
okay after play that threatens queen 86
threatens Queen a six
hmm our queen III is the thing happened
I'm also not sure if I'm meeting here if
it takes on c1 I don't see a maid rook
ahead King b7 Queen a6 don't see a maid
yeah that doesn't work doesn't even
threaten anything ah spoiled it spoiled
it Luke 21 wins pretty simple I'm not
threatening anything Luke g1 is just
made I mean what
still not white yeah and it's no time
left I mean this is just just just
ridiculous a rook g1 is the easiest
whenever I mean yeah I'm just resigning
yeah this is made in water no it's not
you won or whatever I'm not threatening
a single thing right okay add three
seconds yeah so yeah where did i miss
the wind there is a window one hundred
percent say that would be weird if not
well maybe not but yeah it looks like
there should be some kind of win
whoopsie to a1 equal yeah maybe there's
some some perpetual that's it that's
very much possible yeah there's nothing
clear it seems what the engine just
needs more depth to find when you know
it is found when I think but it doesn't
help me much it doesn't help me much
with a with a higher depth thread word
higher depth it might go higher matter
will be some crazy line that nobody can
find yeah thats it's a shame I mean like
right here this position just must
absolutely suck for black this so dirty
54 candy 54 stronger I have Queen f5
checker that's very stupid of course I
saw this move but I thought okay here
but I have the check of course and then
a Bishop f4 thing and then then that is
pretty much stronger where this this
also develops his Bishop and Bishop d3
is probably also stronger am I played a
couple of verse moves
and here it's certainly dangerous but
probably not objectively great yeah III
was better that move I'd expected but it
didn't play it an IP 550 75 a 60 k 7
edits the line that that happened in the
game maybe I should have tried just
tried something else him Queen takes
this to screen b6 that that is not doing
all that much Jay this this was
something that was interesting but I
didn't see a threat to something a yeah
I can play III and I'm not threatening
anything there's no made threat dorm and
then he is quickly counter-attacking I
mean this move is just the thing who
comes first and black comes first he's
got a check and yeah here this is this
is this is winning yeah yeah Queen III
was was also strong with and here would
be seven was a perpetual I can 14
seconds this doesn't threaten all that
much outside I came I didn't know 14
seconds is difficult yeah this is a
fairly check clear perpetual now there
would have been tok white white is just
tons of material up but i had no time on
the clock okay thanks for watching